president Trump's new guidelines to
reopen the economy would roll out in
three phases
China records its first ever contraction
in quarterly GDP and Gilead Sciences
shares soar on reports that the
company's experimental drug may be
performing well in clinical trials
I'm Shelby Holliday and here's what you
need to know today the u.s. death toll
from coronavirus spiked yesterday to
nearly double the prior record as
governors extended lock downs and
president Trump sketched out a
three-phase process to reopen the
economy we're starting our life again
we're starting rejuvenation of our
economy again the guidelines don't
suggest specific dates but put the onus
on governor's to decide based on data
states could enter the first phase after
a downward trend of cases over 14 days
venues including movie theaters
restaurants and gyms could open with
strict social distancing rules in Phase
two non-essential travel and school
activities could resume and bars could
reopen with restrictions for the final
phase people could go back to their
workplaces and visit hospitals China's
economy shrank 6.8% the first such drop
since Beijing started reporting
quarterly GDP numbers in 1992 although
better than economists forecasts the
sharp contraction shows how the country
was hit by unprecedented lock downs and
foreshadows the pain expected globally
retail sales fell around 16 percent in
March much worse than the eight percent
expected by some economists state media
also reported that the death toll in
Wuhan jumped by 50 percent after
officials adjusted the figure to include
people who had died at home and to
correct Mis reporting from overwhelmed
hospitals shares of Gilead Sciences rose
more than 16 percent after hours after a
report that the company's experimental
drug Ram des aveer may be performing
well in clinical trials of kovat 19
patients the health news site stat
reported that a Chicago doctor said most
patients enrolled in a company-sponsored
trial were discharged
however that's far from a final clinical
trial result analysts caution that the
study doesn't include a comparison group
making it difficult to interpret the
results analysts say the drug is
unlikely to be a significant financial
driver for Gilead